the partisan lines in Washington are
clear for the world to see
obviously day to day but one surprising
place where some Democrats and
Republicans are on the same side is over
America's pastime Chris narwall politics
editor here at Fox News and a loyal st.
Louis Cardinals fan unfortunately the
Nats beat them across the board the
National League Championship Series but
anyway too soon okay let's talk about
this and this is a bipartisan support to
save essentially minor league baseball
explain for folks okay so the Major
League Baseball has about 160 minor
league teams what Major League Baseball
wants to do is shuck off the bottom 40
I'm sorry the bottom 40 these are short
season these are the Appalachian leading
this is training leagues this is the new
york pennsylvania league these are
single a and below and they want to
shove those off into something else so
they can focus on the core business of
the hundred and twenty or so remaining
teams that want to dump these 41 focus
on the others and if you live in a town
where one of those smaller teams are
you're probably upset so there's a
bipartisan letter to the commissioner
in which it says reducing the number of
minor league baseball clubs and
overhauling the century-old system that
has been consistently safeguarded by
congress is not in the best interest of
the overall game of baseball especially
when Major League Baseball's revenues
are at all-time highs and those revenues
include 1.2 billion dollars in profits
in 2019 for Major League Baseball the
question is for people like Bernie
Sanders and others is this actually a an
issue to campaign on well look for
Bernie Sanders I'm sure he wishes that
his hometown Vermont Lake Monsters that
play there in Burlington I'm sure he
wishes they kept up their affiliations
and all of that stuff and it's probably
good politics for him at home what
they're talking about is there's a
federal antitrust exemption for Major
League Baseball because they're not
really competitors in the way that Coke
and Pepsi would be competitors they're
actually working together to make a
product so they're not governed by any
trust laws and they can collaborate with
each other to come up with business
plans and stuff like that the
from Congress here is we'll take that
away from you we'll punish you if you
don't operate your business the way that
we tell you because the bipartisan thing
whether you know the difference between
a fungo bat and a Funyun what you know
in Washington is that there is a new
consensus and whether you're a socialist
or whether you're a nationalist you want
you think the government should probably
be running more stuff and telling people
how to run their businesses and that's
why you see people coming together
around ideas like this bottom line
there's major league baseball gonna feel
the pinch from well they're Piggy's at
the trough too because they get all
their free stadiums and they get all of
their tax exemptions on the local level
so they want to kiss up and make people
happy so they're gonna they're leaving
this out here it's getting pummeled in
the end something's gonna happen to
these teams because it's probably not
tenable and they're gonna make some
changes and but they're just going to
Pat the politicians on the hand and say
we promise we'll be very careful all
right before we let you go I want to
we're closing in obviously on our
caucuses February 3rd the latest or most
recent Real Clear Politics average of
polls seems like we're about where we
were which is nationally Biden still
holds roughly what he held exactly a
year ago nationally a lead over Bernie
Sanders Budaj edge and Sanders one and
two with some shake-up in the lower
lower tiers is this rake race kind of
baked right now well look Joe Biden's
fine as long as different he can lose in
Iowa he can lose in New Hampshire
what he can't have is somebody build
momentum coming out of those two states
and going into Nevada it's fine if he
doesn't win either of the first two it
just can't be Elizabeth Warren it can't
be Buddha judge it can't be that Obama
phenomenon that we saw that's what
Buddha judge is very much trying to make
happen here Biden wants to be like Trump
was in 2016 or the way George HW Bush
was in 2000 yeah you could have a
startle here or there but just lead
wire-to-wire
and be the consensus pic well have
plenty of days to talk about that before
February 3rd Chris as always thank you
thank you my friend